you know there's one way to be rational
and there's a lot of way to be
irrational and and that's part of the
the issue with this field is that we
show many ways to be irrational but it's
not just one system it involves a lot of
different things that come to play in
different areas of our lives and the way
to to understand it and to think about
how we fight against them is to think
about what particular irrationality is
working in each particular aspect of our
life whether it's emotion or relativity
or the influence of initial decisions or
the row of expectations all of those can
have input on us and we have to
understand exactly which irrational
forces are working in this particular
case
so so again it's it's I know it's
answered this factory but there's no
single silver bullet the kind of things
I'm hoping that people would get out of
the book is to recognize some early
warning signs for some of those things
so for example I have a chapter about
free that shows that when something is
for free we jump off on it too much and
in fact sometimes end up paying a high
price what can you do is a consequence
you can just slow down you can say I
know free is tempting but when I see it
in the future what they should be doing
is just slow down and think carefully
about whether this is the right thing or
the wrong thing it turns out that real
estate brokers can really change how we
view houses if they show us houses are
outside of our reach they might say look
let's look at this house it's two
hundred thousand dollars more than what
you were planning to buy I don't think
you should buy but just have a look does
not just have a look seeing that would
change a reference price and the way we
think about houses don't let them show
you this house so so there's some
warning signs that we could get the
other thing is there are some things we
can't help so have you ever gone hungry
to a supermarket and bought too much
food everybody does have you learned
after one time never to repeat this
again nobody ever does what is the issue
here when emotion takes over hunger in
this case our stomach seems to grow with
it we seem to be very hungry and we
don't think this hunger will end so what
can we do when hunger takes over we will
become different people that are not
connected to our non aroused non
emotional self so what can we do we can
make a rule for ourselves we can say I
know I make this mistake and if these
emotions are aroused in me I will behave
badly so either go to the supermarket
never go hungry or make a list and never
never never deviate from the list